是这样子的啊，
我和我这个前男友呢，
相处4年分手了，
目前的话就是财产纠纷，
我们分开之后，
像三金彩礼截止他买给我的礼物这些呢，
就是当时情绪比较糟糕吧，
我就都给他了，
下面的问题呢，
就是房子，
房子现在是纠缠不清，
已经一年多了，
房子的贷款是在我一个人名下的，
但是首付呢，
的的确确是男方出的，
像还贷的话呢，
男方是还了有七八个月，
他就不还了，
分手之后这一年多呢，
都是我自己在还，
肯名字问题是怎么回事呢？
因为我自己是有公积金的，
我的公积金呢是比对方多，
然后再还也多嘛，
对方是说要用我的公积金，
但是我们回到老家买房的时候呢，
发现公积金用起来不合适，
贷款年限比较短，
他就说你去写，
那就个商贷嘛，
就写一个人的名字就可以了，
因为写一个人的名字的话，
我想就可以写他的，
这样子的话，
因为毕竟没有结婚嘛，
而且首付是他出的，
我也怕对方父母不同意，
只写我一个人的名字嘛，
这个时候男生提出来要求是说啊，
就写一个人的比较好，
他说是可以给这个家庭留一个买首套房子的优惠名额，
而且他好多承诺说房贷又不用你还，
就不用你担心，
就这个样子写了我的名，
后面不是分手了嘛。
我先说一下我们相处的原因了，
因为我们相处4年，
加上我的年纪也比较大，
轻易的话也不会分。
我跟他从20年到24年，
他就是一直一直各种理由问我借钱，
你比如说他说他爸爸在医院手术不成功，
要重新做手术了，
需要ew，
那我就给他了，
然后说他的信用卡什么，
他过期了，
影响信用了，
这些七七八八的，
七八次一共借走了这15W，
这15W呢，
他是说他每次都承诺还我的，
从来没还过，
他给我的彩礼是12W，
他拿走的是15W，
这个钱不是算结清了嘛，
对吧，
就算说抵下分手也是结清了的，
但是他后续呢，
追着我要什么呢？
那就是说吃饭的钱你要给我多少多少，
然后春节我去你父母那买了礼品，
你要折算什么钱啊之类的，
所以从此以后就一分钱没有再给他，
因为我觉得理不清了，
这个时候说那个房子呢，
房子之前我们是找人协商了的，
就找社区那些协商，
我协商的目的是呢，
就是把房子过户给他，
过户给他的话牵扯到一个大额税，
因为房子没有房产证啊什么的，
还有那个税嘛，
对方提出来说那这个大额税你来出，
又让我出这个，
我也同意了，
但同意之后在社区他不签协议的，
社区让他签，
他也不签，
后来他反悔了，
韩伟现在呢，
带我给了他15W以后，
他说跟他家长辈去村里找，
我们家的长辈都把他找遍了，
说我爸骗婚，
给我爸打电话说我爸骗婚，
然后呢，
他就去我弟弟家，
围绕我弟弟我哥哥家。
意思就是说谋骗婚啊什么的，
现在不是起诉了吗？
他起诉的那个你那个证据啊，
案由是，
嗯，
婚约财产，
婚约财产纠纷，
他起诉的其是，
嗯，
像那个首付呀，
包括他还债贷的部门是20多个W，
他的目的就是说他要这20多个W的所有的钱，
他不要房子，
他不是借了七八次钱嘛，
都是他自己的理由借用了我，
他没还，
我也没要，
但是其中有一个6W，
他是说他姐姐借用了，
我当时是想着给他姐姐做生意，
用了以后也好相处，
后来发现根本都不是他姐姐用的，
不然我转给他外甥，
他为什么转给他，
最终就是他骗我的，
因为当时承诺了，
我说这个钱你到时候结婚之前一定要给我，
因为手里没有什么太多钱了，
当时候生孩子的又一个人上班要还房贷，
压力是非常大的，
我要有一个保障，
他是口头答应了的，
然后这个结婚的日子定下来，
我就问他要了6W嘛，
他不给，
不给的话，
最后我又发现是个大谎言，
然后就因为这个事情听他了的，
现在的话他不是诉我了吗？
我也找律师咨询了，
我们这个律师呢，
他是说让我坦白给法官讲，
因为首付的话，
其中有17W的是现金情式给到我的，
这个男生他也是找不到凭证，
这个律师建议我就是你实话实说，
不管男生有什么证据，
我们跟法官讲真话，
这个首付就是对方付的，
这个事情分手原因是什么？
首付谁是谁出的，
还贷谁还多少，
不管对方有什么证据让我去承认，
因为法官一旦去调查的话。
多多少少都能找到证据，
那坦诚的跟法官讲了，
他说法官可能会能够快速的帮我们解决这个问题，
不是比是说房子男方要我就过户给男方啊，
男方不要的话呢，
我们就协商卖掉，
卖掉肯定是赔钱的，
什么时候能赔个2/3，
但是赔钱的话，
我们具体是要承担多少，
经过法官去，
呃裁决嘛，
裁决我要承担多少，
我也去真酌的去，
去弄这个时间的，
是这样子的，
现在的话就是我一个原因是因为想啊，
这个律师他要求我就坦诚的讲了，
我也可以坦诚，
但是从始至终啊，
这个男生在我跟他闹分手的时候，
我看他在截图，
在调那些证据，
我是说我坦诚的之候，
这个男生对于我们什么时候提去买房的，
为什么要写我一个人的影象，
这个男生就从来没有坦诚过我，
如果坦生我最后一点点对我有利的东西，
这个男生可能反口或来把我咬死，
所以我就不知道我该不该坦诚，
另外的话，
这个案子最终怎么办，
我心里嗯，
不太一底，
我就是想要听听您这边的意见，
这样子的啊，
如果男方那边他有证据，
比如他有取款记录，
虽然说他没有打款给你的记录，
但是他的取款记录和你们去买房子那个时间线能够对起，
颗粒度能对齐，
并且你这头突然怎么就多出来17万了呢？
你之前这17万是从哪里来的呢？
你的是工资攒下来的呢？
还是谁借给你？
你的吗？
那谁借给你的话也有一个，
呃，
来龙去脉呀，
但是你又没有办法说明你这17万的现金是从哪来的，
你突然就有钱卖房了，
那这个法官会形成一个很强的新政，
他确实是给了你17万的现金哦，
嗯，
所以一个是你与其撒谎还不如说实话，
我就是觉得我一直来讲，
我就是很坦诚认这个事情，
因为以前跟他聊天记录嘛，
我们都会承认这个事情，
这个事情从来没有回避过，
我只是说我坦诚这个事情对于我达到我的诉求都没有好处，
因为这个男生他从始至终他都是很难捏我的，
我这么说好不好，
姑娘，
你不坦诚这个事情对你的话有坏处在，
最终一定会被法院查出来的，
因为有人聊天记录，
人家有取款的记录，
然后跟你们买房的时间线能对得上，
而你本人之前又没有那么多存款，
这些全加在一起的话，
那要会形成一个新政，
那形成这个地证，
如果你不坦诚，
不说真话的话，
对你一定是有坏处的，
对你坦诚没有好处，
但是你隐瞒欺骗是有坏处的，
好，
那现在已经主意了，
那就是听了本律师的这个坦诚的来讲，
也缩短这个去调查，
就看来这个时效，
争取把这个事情早一点点解决，
最坏的结局就是人家出的每一分钱都还给他，
当然这个你就承担了房价降价的损失。
值这个东西，
假设最坏的几因女如们要去承担的话，
那我们只能这么想，
就是谁也料想不到这个房子会降价，
就是当初我做这个决策的时候，
是我自己也是一个成年人，
我做了这样的决策，
那我承担这个房屋降价的这样一个后果的话，
好像从逻辑上来讲的话，
也能说服自己，
因为当初这房子也是我同意买的，
也是我同意买到我名下的，
为什我同意以我的名义去贷款的房子降价连谁都不想，
但这一结局的话，
从某种因果关系上来说的话，
如果有一天虽然说听上去对你是不公平的啊，
我们都知道对你不公平，
因为这事儿买房子是两个人要结婚买的，
又不是买给你一个人的，
但是假设面对那样的结果的话，
我们自己心里也要有这样的心理准备吧，
啊，
这是最坏的情况，
在其次的结果就是你们两个人共同去承担房屋亏损的部分，
那还有一种心态给你了另一种思路，
只要这房子你不卖，
你自己住，
他亏是暂时的，
你把时间在线拉长了，
拉到10年，
拉到20年，
20年时候他可能就不亏了，
就是说房子里在我名下结更开始啊，
就是面发生一些恶心的事情的时候，
他别去家里面，
嗯，
去说骗婚啊什么的，
因为我已经给了他15个，
远远比他给我的彩礼啊，
什么包括他爸妈给我的红包，
一分都没花，
这些都是给了他的，
如果说别发生这种两家人之间争执啊，
放在我这。
那给他我也能接受，
但现在是我心理上就是没办法接受，
比如说这个房子留在我名下，
后面万一涨价了，
他们家的父母啊什么的再来闹腾，
而且我以后跟我假如我在杨文，
我住在那个里面，
我就是心里上觉得想跟他撇的干干净净的，
一点关系都没有，
如果2万都不要，
都别强求卖掉好了，
卖掉的话其些损失多少我也愿意说就就入法官的那个嘛，
那我怎么给法官去争取，
就是说尽量按照，
尽量不要让这个房贷留到我名下呢，
那我不管从长时间的房贷还是经济方面，
我不太能接受，
那你最好是从经济上，
呃远从经济上收服法官，
你说我没有能力偿还这个贷款，
嗯，
行，
那如果说一审当中，
比如说判见说你俩都不要，
那房子法拍吧，
那如果到这种地步的话，
像我还有没有权利去卖这个房子，
因为我前面不敢卖，
我就是怕有争执吗？
如果说医生真的说法，
哎，
那我这个人还能去卖吗？
因为我卖肯定比法判卖的高，
这个应该是有协商的空间的，
你自己能卖，
对于法国来说也是省事，
你先，
嗯，
那个方合10边没什么问题了，
好想开点啊，
姑娘今好没结婚，
你好没生孩子，
就是现在对于你来说所有的损失都是钱上的损失，
身体上今年想精神上还相对来说。
好一些，
好，
我这说话啊，
我原来还遇到一个更生气的，
更气人的，
比连麦这个姐妹更惨，
原来那个就是说房子虽然在女方名下，
贷款在女方名下，
然后贷款一直是女方在还，
但是实际上住那个房子的是男方，
男方的父母，
人家在那个房子里面住的可好了，
然后打那个婚约财产纠纷嘛，
男方就要求这女方又要退钱啊，
法院判下来确实给退钱，
为什么？
因为房子在女方的名下，
从产权上来说，
这房子是归女方的，
然后他俩没结成婚就该退他那个钱，
但是这房子女方自己又住不进去，
也卖不掉，
为什么？
一旦说要让人看房，
然后男方和男方的父母住在那套房子里，
那真的就是气人哦，
因为女孩子这方吧，
自己娘家人又没有那种五大三粗的那个男的去给他撑腰，
爸爸妈妈也没有这个能力去帮他解决这个问题，
你要说龙飞姐能解决这个问题吗？
这边法官去了都不一定能解决，
真的。